hello and welcome to this video 3 of no
no what is that T really wrong wrong
wrong because he really cares whatever
is on the water first
[Music]
yeah that's um that's one of the better
lighting this night bt7
how do you play this a five I think
black should go in five now and I think
we never three was my suggestion but
sometimes a bit trickier compatibility
for repertoire and the lines that you
get on the board really frequently
things like a 45
the Sicilian those things I really
remember well but the lines like this
the parents in you don't get too often
and I keep forgetting the lines I mean I
don't really refresh my repertoire I've
written it and I've worked on the paper
version of the book for a while so that
also made me repeat some things but I'm
not repeating my learning progress for
example or chasuble at the moment which
makes it difficult to keep in mind order
all the sight lines and less and less
popular openings okay what I do know is
that this cannot be bad for why there
would be very reiative it was they have
a huge space advantage on the kingside
and I'm simply threatening g5 f6 and
black basically as toast if I get
nothing no would be surprising if not
the issue is also that currently if I do
G 5 f6 the bishop will be completely
entombed on age 8 he almost has to move
the evade rock okay threatening f6
killing the hook inside now it probably
has to do something drastic
but I mean I'm thinking about taking on
their five play d4 so but that is just
going to be pretty awful okay so the
check is super obvious and now h5 yeah
guess so
yeah the bishop is such a such an
enormous piece I wanted want to keep it
of course I just wonder I could take on
g6 maybe take that first
hmm
hey I don't know this is this is good
enough huh but I was thinking there's
something even even more powerful like I
didn't see anything
okay so G takes my idea was to go Queen
to h5 but maybe that isn't actually that
clear
[Music]
it isn't that clear
hmm but take here F takes G five and
maybe I'm just maybe I'm just not
relaxed enough yeah I mean that must be
good enough to win now rook takes h7 is
the S to take Bishop f5 right you should
take that v is forced and then Queen age
five I was thinking when I'm not sure
yeah this is this is just Mariam
King takes can take Zeus and meet ya
okay so Queen f3 here I think probably
be five immediately it's the way to go
I'm fairly fairly certain that black
should not allow this yeah okay the
engine is not totally hating it just
have a pawn but that could change um
this is not this is not working right
no just too much yeah I was thinking
that htx g6 could be hornik already in
the engine so believe this is better
here and Queen h5 is better well this
this should be should be plenty plenty
of of plane threatening g6 now and I
really don't see what he's doing against
it threat
in de Bishop e6 seems to be a threat
some jobs Andrew gave one yeah I mean
okay ed is too much
the H file and this fantastic bishop
must be when must be doing okay guys
thanks for watching